[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALOK CHANDEL: Hi.
All right.
My name is Alok Chandel.
I am the user experience
lead for foldable devices
on the Android platform team.
And in this session,
we'll be talking
about how to build apps for
foldables, multi display,
and large screen devices.
Now, we'll start by looking
at the range of devices
which are going to
benefit from this session.
Then we will take a look at
some of the user experience
considerations that
you should keep in mind
as you are designing your apps.
Then we will dive
a little bit deeper
into app continuity, multi
window, and multi display.
We are also delighted to
hear from our partners
from Gameloft and 1Password.
And finally, we'll
finish it off by looking
at how you can test your apps
before you even get your hands
on these foldable devices.
So let's get started.
When we talk about
foldable devices,
we are specifically looking
at the devices which
have a display which can fold.
Now, they come in
two broad categories.
Number one is when
you fold the device,
the flexible display
is on the inside.
An example of that is
the Samsung Galaxy Fold.
Now, typically these
devices will also
have an additional
screen on the outside
so that even when
the phone is folded,
you can use it as a one
handed configuration, maybe
for doing some quick actions.
The other category is
when you fold the phone,
the display is on the outside.
This is the fold
out configuration,
such as Huawei Mate X. Now,
when these devices are folded,
some part of the display
is still available like
to use as a regular phone in
a one handed configuration.
Now, I'm sure you have
heard this, that Android
is supporting foldables.
But what does this
really mean for you?
What this means is that if
you follow some of the best
practices, such as resizability,
handling configuration changes,
and using saved
instance state, your app
should just work out of
the box on these completely
new and innovative form factors.
That's really the power
of when a platform is
supporting these new devices.
Now, Android
supports innovation.
But you are the innovators.
And we are so excited to
see the kind of experiences
that you are going to
create on these new devices.
Now, another interesting thing
that you need to keep in mind
is that once you optimize
your applications to run well
on these sort of large,
unfolded displays,
they will also work equally
well on hundreds of millions
of Android tablets which
are already out there,
as well as the Chrome OS devices
which are capable of running
Android apps.
Now, let's take a look
at the UX considerations
that you should pay
attention to when building
your apps for these devices.
Immersive experiences.
Once you unfold these
devices, whether they
are 7 inch or 8 inch
display, they're
just absolutely gorgeous.
And you want to make
sure that you are really
taking advantage of every single
pixel that is available to you.
So these are really good
for things like gaming,
for watching videos,
both consuming, and more
importantly, creating
content for social media,
as well as they
are just absolutely
amazing for productivity.
So really make sure
that you are embracing
these large, full
screen experiences.
Next, once these
devices are folded--
because that's where
the magic happens.
You can fold it, and
keep it in your pocket.
You still want to make sure
that you are taking advantage
of the fact that these
devices can be used
in a one handed operation also.
So depending upon the
size of the screen that
is available to the user
once the phone is folded,
it may be just for
taking quick action.
It may also be just
used as a regular phone.
So make sure that your
apps are respecting
both of these configurations.
Finally, multitasking.
This is one of those fields
which is gaining more
importance with these devices.
A lot of times you will see that
these devices are coming out
with nearly square form
factor, or very close to it.
What that means is that you
can run two 18x9 windows next
to each other, side by side.
So when you are
multitasking, you're
multitasking between
almost two full displays
next to each other.
So make sure that you
are taking advantage
of these new opportunities.
Now, speaking about
new aspect ratios,
this is something that
we definitely encourage
you to pay attention to.
You are probably already very
familiar with aspect ratios
like 16x9, or 18x9.
Now, with these
devices, start thinking
about new aspect ratios, which
can go as high as 21 inch
to 9", or even beyond.
And on the other hand, then
they can go as small as 1 inch
to 1", like almost
square displays.
So we really
encourage you to think
about how your apps
are going to look
across all of these
different aspect ratios.
Now, we understand
that for some reason
you may feel that these
extreme aspect ratios do not
provide the right kind of
experience for your users.
So we already have
the max aspect ratio
attribute that you can use
to limit how big it can go.
We are also introducing
in Android Q
a minAspectRatio attribute.
So this allows you to have
a true control over exactly
how your apps are going
to look across all
the different range of devices
that you're going to see.
Now, talking about screens,
we are introducing a change
which is more like a
clarification in Android Q
to make sure that every
display that comes out
with these foldable devices,
or devices in general,
has a minimum width
of two inches.
Now, this is important
because, A, we
want to make sure that
you have enough space
to comfortably put up to
five icons in your nav bar.
As well as, there is sufficient
space for a keyboard input.
Now, with that, I would like
to invite on stage Adrian.
[APPLAUSE]
ADRIAN ROOS: Thanks Alok.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Adrian.
I'm a software
engineer on Android,
and I'm the lead on foldables.
So let's talk a
bit more about how
you can make sure that your
apps work well on these new form
factors.
One of the important
things you can do
is ensure that your app
supports app continuity.
So what is that really?
It's what we call
the concept of being
able to have your app seamlessly
change between the fold
and the unfold states without
losing any state of the user.
So in this example here, you
might have a video player.
If the user is watching a
video, and they fold or unfold,
they don't want to
lose that state.
They still want to
look at the same video.
And playback
shouldn't interrupt.
So on a technical level,
what this really comes down
to is handling
configuration changes.
Folding and unfolding
is really nothing other
than the screen size and
the configuration changing.
And this has existed on
Android for a while now.
We have a great developer
guide on our website
on developer.android.com.
And it goes into a lot
of detail on what to do,
and how to handle those
configuration changes.
But sort of the most important
things to look out for
are that you always
choose the right layout
when the configuration
change happens
to really take advantage of
the added screen real estate,
or properly fit it if the
screen size reduces when you
fold the device back closed.
And another thing you really
need to pay attention to
is restoring state that the
user is currently experiencing,
like positions in
scroll layouts,
or something like the
current page in a view page,
or where the user currently
is in a tab navigation.
And also really make sure
to not drop any input
the user has already entered,
like text in a text view,
or where the keyboard
focus currently is.
Let's also talk a bit more about
Android resizable activity.
So this is a manifest flag
that we introduced together
with multi window support
quite a while ago.
And it indicates
whether an activity
can run in a different
configuration
than what the global
screen configuration is.
And when you think
about it, it's
really required
for multi window.
Right?
Because your app might not
occupy the whole screen.
And so it needs to experience
a smaller configuration
than the whole screen.
The name is a bit
unfortunate, however,
because even if you set
this to [INAUDIBLE],,
it doesn't mean that
you never experience
a resize in your activity.
Because the orientation of
the display might change.
Or now with foldables, also
the effective screen size
might change.
And you still need
to handle that.
So even if you set
resizable activity to false,
make sure that your test
configuration changes even
with such activities.
Now, there is one case where
previous to foldable phones,
we didn't really expose your
activities to configuration
changes ever.
And that was for orientation
locked activities
that are also not resizable,
so don't support multi window.
And for those activities, we are
introducing a new compatibility
mode in Android Q, which
ensures that your apps don't
see a configuration change.
Instead, they get letterboxed
and scaled to fit the screen.
And the user, of
course, has then
the option to
restart your activity
in the new native screen size.
However, for the
best user experience,
we recommend that you avoid
falling into this case,
and support multi
window by setting
resizable activity to true.
All right.
So speaking of multi window,
on these form factors
with increase screen
size, multi window
is really getting more
important to take advantage
of all that screen space.
And so I'd also like to talk
a bit more about what changes
we made, and how to take
best advantage of that.
In Andrew Q, one of the
biggest multi window changes
is the introduction
of multi-resume.
And so the change from
previous versions of Android
is that previously only
at most one activity
could be resumed
at the same time.
And it was not really indicated
to a user which one that is.
And so it got a bit
confusing if one activity
might react a bit differently
than another, even though it
looks totally the same.
And it was also
one more state you
had to worry about
as a developer
without really gaining anything.
So to simplify things,
starting with Android Q,
we are just keeping all the top
focusable activities resumed.
So in this example here,
all three activities
are in the resumed state in
this situation on Android Q.
However, be aware
that you can still
end up in the paused state
if there's a transparent
activity launched on top of
you, or if your activity isn't
actually currently
focusable, such as in picture
in picture mode.
So multi-resume
should mostly just
work out of the box
for all apps really.
But one important case
that needs to be handled
is multi-resume
together with using
exclusive resources, such as
the camera or the microphone.
So now that more activities
are resumed at the same time,
it may happen that
you are resumed,
but someone else
is actually trying
to access the same
resource that you are.
So in this case here, if
you launch three camera apps
simultaneously, obviously
only one of them
can get the access
to the camera.
So make sure that even
if you are resumed,
you handle the own
disconnected callbacks that you
might get with the camera.
And also, reconnect once the
camera becomes available again.
Also, to note this that
even if you disable
multi window with
resizable activity false,
it does not really
guarantee exclusive access,
because there might
be a floating activity
on top of you, or with
multi display devices
you might actually even
have a resumed activity
on a totally different display.
We are adding a new callback
to activity, which tells you
about the top resumed state.
And that really just
corresponds to what
resumed used to mean on
previous platform versions.
And then finally, I'd also like
to talk about drag and drop
quickly.
Drag and drop is
really becoming a lot
more important and powerful
now that multi window
is becoming more prevalent.
But that all depends
on you and your apps
actually implementing that.
Again, there's a great
dev guide online.
Please check that out.
And if drag and drop makes sense
for your app, please add it.
And with that, I'd like to
welcome Michael to the stage.
He's going to talk about
his experience applying
all of this.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL VERDE: Thanks, Adrian.
My name's Michael.
I'm the team lead for 1Password
on the Android platform.
And 1Password is a
secure way of storing
your most sensitive data.
We store things like your login
credentials, your banking,
credit card details,
and much more.
But it isn't sufficient to
just store that information.
It needs to be accessible to
you when and where you need it
in a way that's
natural and effortless.
Am I not coming through?
Can everyone hear me now?
In a way that's natural and
effortless on the devices
that you are using.
So this pursuit of meeting you
where you are on the platforms
that you use originally led us
to pursue developing 1Password
for the Android
platform, and then
to optimize it for tablets.
Then to optimize it for Chrome
OS, and now for foldables.
And in the process of
doing so, what we've done
is we've created this
sequence of steps
where we've iteratively improved
the user experience for the app
on each successive platform.
And with each new
platform that we add,
we then are able to leverage
and build upon the improvements
from the previous ones.
When Android apps first
launched on Chrome OS,
we knew that we wanted to
be there, because it was
where people were using apps.
Chrome OS had breakaway success
in the education market.
It is now a market
leader for laptops.
And so we wanted to be there
too where our users are.
And we wanted to provide
a seamless experience that
provided a responsive
layout, and allowed
us to take advantage of the
optimizations and the design
layout that we'd done to
use the larger real estate
available on tablet devices.
So what that
necessitated for us was
to make use of
resizable activity,
and to allow our
activity to be created.
So one of the challenges
that we encountered
was that in the process
of allowing our activity
to be re-created, we discovered
that while the very first thing
that happened was it crashed.
And this happened
as a result of us
depending on config changes
flags in the manifest.
So what would happen is we'd
try to resize the window.
And in the process of
trying to resize the window,
1Password would crash, because
we were trying to manually
handle configuration
changes ourselves,
instead of letting the
framework handle it for us.
What we did to
resolve that issue
was to remove those
config changes
flags from the manifest,
refactor our code,
so that we weren't
dependent upon configuration
changes being handled manually.
And instead, we
allowed the framework
to do what it was
supposed to do, which is,
recreate the activity,
and then load
the appropriate resources
based on the configuration
parameters.
That worked to
resolve the crash.
But unfortunately, it
exposed another issue for us.
And that issue was
that now 1Password,
when you would resize the
window, it would lock.
Now, 1Password needs to lock
in order to protect user data.
We don't want people to be
able to access your data when
you're not intending them
to have access to it.
And so when you leave the
app, or after a certain amount
of time 1Password will lock.
But we certainly
didn't intend for it
to lock every time you
would resize the window.
It turned out that this was a
side effect of some assumptions
that we'd made about
the activity lifecycle
but actually didn't
hold true in practice.
So we had to go back and we had
to reexamine these assumptions
and rectify them in our code.
And once we did, we were able
to deliver an experience that
was a reflowable, adaptive
experience that took advantage
of the real estate available on
the device based on the window
size available.
So for us, one of the big
lessons and the big takeaways
was really we just need
to get out of our own way
and let the framework
do what it does best.
In the case of
activity resizing,
we need to stop trying
to handle config changes
ourselves and actually
let the framework do it.
In the case of drag and
drop, for example, we just
needed to add a
few lines of code,
and append a couple
XML attributes.
And that took care of itself.
So be mindful of
assumptions that you're
making around things like
activity life cycles.
And be aware of the tools that
are there in the frameworks,
and Android best
practices that help
you to deliver the seamless
experience that you
want to deliver.
And if your experience
is anything like ours,
when you follow those
practices, the rest of it
will fall into place,
and you'll end up
with an excellent user
experience across multiple form
factors and environments.
And with that, I'd like to
welcome Ian from Gameloft
to talk about their
experience bringing "Asphalt
9" to more than just phones.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
IAN LOHE CHUNG: Can you hear me?
My name is Ian.
I'm a platform lead
developer at Gameloft.
So first I'll start
with a shameless plug.
For those of you wondering,
this game is "Asphalt 9."
So if you haven't
already checked it out,
I invite you to try it out
on the Google Play Store.
If you guys were
to ask me how it
was to develop on Android
a couple of years ago,
I would have said,
the screen is static.
The resolution's
never going to change.
The input method, it's touch,
maybe even multi-touch.
That's not going to--
there is no keyboard.
There's no mouse.
Like all that stuff,
that's for PC.
Memory is limited.
Network, be super careful
with network conditions,
cause it's really slow.
But if you were to ask me
the same question today,
I would say, you would have
to make a game that runs on,
I have no idea.
Basically it has to run
on absolutely anything.
So the way we
approach this is we
tried to develop for something
we call a device unknown.
A device unknown means
we can make no assumption
about the device
we're targeting.
Device unknown has any
resolution and all resolutions
at the same time.
The resolution could even
change at runtime dynamically.
And the way we'll do
that is our editor
would allow the game designers
to anchor different UI elements
to each other, to
the screen edges,
and whatnot, and even allow
them to resize it in real time
so they can preview
what the game looks
like at different resolutions
as they're editing it.
And this allows
them to be creative
while the engine
takes care of all
of the grunt work
behind the scenes.
This unknown device also
has different input types.
It has keyboard.
It has mouse, which
is a single touch.
Like it's a single input,
as opposed to multi-touch.
Controllers, touch.
Like we actually don't know.
And we try to
support everything.
And the way we do this is we
try to guess the user's intent
based on where he is in
the game at the time,
along with the different
components that
are connected to the device.
So, for example, if he has
a controller connected,
and he's in a race,
chances are he's
going to want to use
it to play the game.
We also assume that
everything's dynamic.
We have no idea what
hardware specs there actually
are on the device.
We have, for example,
different GPUs, different CPU
frequencies, different
amounts of memory.
And the way we do that is
we'll detect all the specs,
put it all together,
do some magic,
and figure out what effects
should be turned on and off,
or the texture level
that we should be
making in that particular game.
And that allows us to
have the high end devices
at top quality, while the
lower end devices will still
have super good
response, and a good FPS.
But it's the same
APK basically that's
running on all the devices.
And the final step is that
everything is dynamic.
So we have no idea what
the screen size is.
We can't assume that the
screen size at the beginning
will be the same as at the end.
And we have no idea when
a user will plug something
into the device at hand.
And, of course, we're wrong.
And we know that, because
there's no way to do all this.
So we'll always allow the user
to go into the game settings,
and go and change his
input method, or whatever.
So basically our
takeaway here was,
you can no longer develop
for one single device.
We have to develop
for all devices.
And assume that you
don't know anything,
because we have no idea what new
devices will appear tomorrow.
And now I'll hand
it off to Andrii.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDRII KULIAN: Thank you, Ian.
And hi, everyone.
I am Andrii.
I am a software engineer
with Android framework window
manager team.
And I work on multi display.
So foldable phones may
have several screens.
But you can also find
multi display in cars,
in phones connected to larger
screens in desktop mode,
in Chrome OS, and so on.
And the same best
practices that we implement
to handle screen size
changes, orientation changes,
or multi window will
let your app work
well in all of these use cases.
Let's start with activities.
There can be several
ways how one can end up
on a different display.
On foldable devices, it
can move between displays
when the user folds or
unfolds the display.
And on all platform
versions, a regular start
from launcher or from
system can create
a new instance of activity
on a secondary screen.
Or it can find an existing
one on a different screen
and move it from there.
The actual behavior will
depend on the launch mode
that you define in
Android manifest,
and also the intent flags and
options that the caller sets
who starts the activity.
When moved to a
different screen,
you should keep in mind that
the following things can happen.
A context may be
updated, window resized.
And configuration and
resource may change.
So let's talk about
context a bit.
The activity context,
which is a visible entity,
is different from non
visual application context,
also available from services
and other non visual components.
And the context of
a visible entity
is always adjusted to the
screen area where it is shown.
So to get the current display
metrics, size, and resources,
make sure to always use
the current visual context,
such as activity.
Also, some system APIs will
get display information
from the context you provide.
For example, if you want to make
sure that a toast will show up
on the same screen as
the current activity,
it's probably better to
use the activity context.
And in general, it's
usually wrong to try
to get display metrics or
resources from non activity
contexts, because, for
example, application
is a non visual entity.
You can get the result
that can be completely
for a totally different screen.
In most cases, you can
expect different screens
on the device to have
different sizes, densities,
and resolutions.
And this means that the
activity will probably
get a configuration change.
And if it declared to handle
the change in Android manifest,
it will get a notification.
If not, it will be relaunched.
And in some cases,
it may be even better
to handle the configuration
change yourself,
because it may result in a
more fluid user experience.
Configuration also drives the
resources in your application.
So make sure to update
the user's assets
and layouts whenever the
configuration changes.
And if you need to know what
the current display [INAUDIBLE]
is after some changes
happened onCreate and
onConfigurationChanged
are good places to check.
Also, when an activity
moves between screens,
there can be multiple
configuration values
that change at the same time.
Here is an example.
In addition to size
and density changes,
screen properties like
orientation, layout,
and even support for
touch will change as well.
Any of these, even
a single one, can
cause an activity relaunch
if you don't declare
that your activity handles it.
If the declared launch
mode for an activity
allows multiple tasks, then
start on the secondary screen
may create a new
instance of activity.
For example, in this
case, the caller,
requested launch
on second display
with flags, new task,
and multiple task,
and it's created a new window
of Chrome on the second display.
It's best for you to check
what kind of experience
you would like to provide
for your application.
And if you want to support
something like this,
consider using a shared source
of data in multiple view
models.
And also, take advantage of
other architecture components.
Multi-resume also applies
to multi screen scenarios.
And several activities
can receive user input
at the same time, even if they
are from the same application.
So keep in mind that activities
could receive input even
in a non focused state on
previous Android versions.
You can try that out
if you try to interact
with both apps in split
screen at the same time.
And they will both
respond in most cases.
Focus in the system
usually defines where
the untargeted input will go.
For example, where will go the
key events from the keyboard?
So what if you want to use
those additional screens?
First step is to
learn what displays
are available in the system by
checking with display manager.
The displays may have
different characteristics.
You can check their flags,
their metrics, and their state
to find the one you want to use.
For example, you can
look for a large screen
to present your media content.
Or you can filter
out the displays
that are currently off.
Sometimes the system may
restrict activity launches
on certain displays.
For example, a display
may be private.
In this case, a call
to start an activity
will throw a security exception.
In Q we added a new API to
check if current security
restrictions will
allow the caller
to successfully start an
activity on a specific display.
And finally, you can
launch your activity there
by using the Activity Options
API added in Android O.
Let's speak about
new additions in Q.
We added support for
software keyboard window
on secondary screens.
There is still only one software
keyboard window in the system,
but it can move between screens.
And move to a different display
is handled in similar ways
to display change, like
when rotation happens.
The system will send the
display configuration change
to the keyboard process.
And it will update the context
and resources at runtime.
We also added support
for wallpapers.
And Android
framework will create
a separate instance
of wallpaper service
engine for each display.
So if you want
your live wallpaper
to support multiple
screens, make
sure that the surface of each
engine is drawn independently.
And you can declare support
for multiple screens
for your wallpapers by enabling
this in fold paper info XML
definition.
Another important addition
is support for launchers
on secondary screens.
We added an entire new
category to intent filter
to provide dedicated activity
for secondary screens.
Instances of this
activity will be
used on all displays that have
enabled system decorations.
One display will have one
instance of such activity.
It must have a launch
mode that does not
prevent multiple instances.
And it is expected to adapt
to different screen sizes.
A user can set the launcher of
their choice on their device.
And if the currently
chosen launcher
has a dedicated activity
for secondary screens,
it will be put
there by the system.
The [INAUDIBLE] implementation
now includes this.
And we also put a sample
multi display launcher
that showcases how to use some
of these new capabilities.
So the next question is,
how can you test all this?
We realize it's often very hard
to get the latest and greatest
hardware.
So we added support for foldable
devices in Android Emulator
so you can start
building right away.
Currently, there are 7.3"
and 8 inch emulators.
And we will be adding
more screen sizes
as we see more devices
launching in the market.
You can use the [? fold ?]
emulator to test app continuity
to see how
compatibility mode works
for apps that declare fixed
orientation or aspect ratio.
And you can also check
out how the multi-resume
will impact your application.
To test multi display
on real devices, in Q
we added a new developer option
called forced desktop mode.
When enabled, it will turn
on the system decorations
on all supported screens.
And it will also show
mouse pointer there
instead of the default display.
Combined with enabling
free form windows, also
from developer options,
this will create a desktop
like windowing experience.
These, and some other
windowing related options,
usually require a device
reboot to start functioning,
just so you know.
On Pixel you can try it using a
simulated screen, which you can
also find in developer options.
And if you have a device
which hardware supports
HDMI, or Display Port
[INAUDIBLE] over USB-C,
you can test it using the
wired connection as well.
We also released
a developer guide
for foldable and
multi screen devices
today on the Android
Developer website.
We put the best practices
and in-depth information
there that we think should help
you making your app work in all
of these environments.
So definitely check it out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]